more than a thousand casino workers
rallying on the las vegas strip tonight
fighting for everyone who was laid off
during the pandemic to get their jobs
back orco man and our team was there
joining us now live in the strip with
their message orco
well brian the lights here on this strip
are shining bright as tourists continue
coming to las vegas and while many in
the hospitality industry are back to
work some are not tonight's rally was
about getting everyone their jobs back
[Music]
passionate pleas to get back to work
more than a thousand hospitality workers
shutting down part of the las vegas
strip thursday night for the we will
come back stronger rally hosted by the
culinary union for the last 20 months
i've been out of work and it has been
very hard alber mora worked at a bake
shop inside caesar's palace for 12 years
but was laid off in april 2020 during
the covet shutdown while others have
gotten their jobs back albert has not
the hotel says there is no enough
business to bring it back all the people
that
is not working now he is not alone
according to the culinary union around
35 percent of their members are still
not back to work
that's why they're sending their message
right in front of properties on the
strip which is once again bustling with
activity las vegas back in a lot of ways
you know and we have we still have 20
000 people within back to work yet and
they're ready other unions standing in
solidarity with the casino workers if
our brothers and sisters have an issue
we have an issue so we're here to
support them with their issue alber is
thankful for the encouragement and
hopeful for the future we will come back
and we will come back soon
the culinary union wants to make it
clear tonight's rally was not a protest
against any casino company it was simply
a way to share their message to the
industry as a whole reporting live
tonight on the las vegas strip orc omana
live local now